(soft knocking)
- [Zelda] Look who's here.
- Hi, Zelda, how you doing?
- I never knew there was
a school in the building.
I got a note one day to show up,
and I loved it from the moment we began.
(soft lighthearted music)
(fast exciting music)
- My name is Zelda Fassler.
I'm a resident of the Hebrew Home.
I've been working with the HOPE class
since just about two
months after I got here.
- [Teacher] What kind of
feelings do you guys get
from this painting over here?
- The whole program is very unique
because it's a high school
within a nursing home facility.
You guys can just turn to the second page.
The whole program is a vocational program
that started back in the '90s,
that gives students with
intellectual disabilities
the opportunity to
split their time between
being in their different departments,
their academic studies.
And then working with the residents
and interact with them on a daily basis.
I think it's a win win
for both the residents
and the students.
They share ideas, past experiences,
and gain different perspectives
on how life is today.
(playful music)
- I feel that most of them
are like grandchildren to me.
I see them around the
home, we stop, we talk.
Some of them knock on my door.
Wanda, she'll just come in for a hug.
The twins come in for a hug.
It's a lovely feeling.
The thrifty social worker.
I'm lucky to have that.
And the longer we're
together, the closer we get.
And the more they look
to me as a grandparent,
I think they think of me in that way,
because I never act like a teacher.
I'm there to help them,
to explain things to them.
To be his executor.
- Oh.
- Not executer.
(laughing)
(playful music)
It's what keeps my mind fresh;
it's what keeps me feeling young.
People say you move into a nursing home
and that's it.
But the HOPE class gives
my life here meaning.